but that's gonna say this is like it's
this you know this another phenomena
about auditioning that's hilarious is
when you are in the room and you're
waiting and there's a person goes in and
it's 25 minutes that person that they
come out and do that
ok good a nice person goes in in 15 20
minutes go by and you're conscious of
the time that each guy is spending in
the room and you get in there and some
of you do it and you feel like okay that
would look great thanks you don't like
one scene yeah and you're done and you
walk out the room there's that a that
feeling where you're thinking yourself
what the hell I was in that for like 30
minutes maybe he said just you and then
you try to rationalize it you're like
maybe time just seemed to pass really
quickly because I was in the auditioning
room but when I'm outside of the room
the maybe it doesn't and then there's a
walk of shame they'll get you're like
you using I think as all the guys like I
always try to also brush my skin like
okay either they think I did a really
bad job maybe I did it so amazing that
there's nothing we could say I yeah
that's the worst
I am forgot what I was gonna say about
all this it sounds good oh yeah I
think that's what we need I think we got
enough from you that I think that's
pretty solid
it wasn't gonna say um it's not like you
can make hear the other people on the
audition that is inevitable so when you
call me about hearing oh yeah
do that on that yeah I do like some
stand up about it yeah about like people
that walk in and try can I psych you out
you don't like the guy that Nick comes
in with like a motorcycle helmet
although he like drove his car there
right now he's like I'll tussle and he's
like oh you need to put my motorcycle
down on this chair my mother
down in this chair because it needs its
own space you know and the whole idea of
like hearing someone is it's like they
like sex you out a little bit and stuff
I go watch it it's on YouTube I'll watch
it yeah I like it
this isn't but you feel self-conscious
about them in those rooms where you know
the walls are so thin because I had an
audition where it was all girls and I
was the only one reading this one guys
part and all the girls parts were just
very conversational yeah they would go
in the room and I could work for work
hirotaka just being like well Molly I
think we should go to the store and buy
bread really yeah we need some it's like
I'm just thinking of all these girls ah
yeah oh great here we go but that is
kind of a process of where you have to
willfully be able to just shut down a
certain part of your brain and say like
alright screw it I'm not gonna be
concentrating on that it's gonna
concentrate on this exclusively what you
can do with varying levels of success I
mind
I find that when you know people always
say oh it's so that actors so brave you
know in their work and I find that you
know there there is a lot of bravery and
commitment that takes to one year when
you're actually working
I feel like auditioning it takes so much
more bravery because you're putting
yourself out there for someone to say
you're you you did a good job you did a
bad job you know what even more so than
then acting you know when you actually
have the job you're on auditioning
you're you know you can tell right away
when someone you know I was like oh okay
oh alright thanks a lot thanks for
coming in you know you tell right away
all that person didn't like that what I
just did many voices you know and it's
so I don't know it takes a lot more cuts
by the kind of doing an audition than
actually having the job it's and it's I
think it's a totally different skill set
auditioning and then doing the work no
they're they're related in certain
respects but they're very very different
and I think some people like you're
saying before are incredibly good at
auditioning and then not necessarily
that great as a performer at the end of
the day now and vice-versa there are
people who just absolutely can't
audition but are really nice actors at
the end of the day and it it's it's just
it's strange that that is the portal
that you have to walk through in order
to be able to do the work and it's it's
almost like you know and they they do
classes where they you know this class
is about acting classes then there are
specific here it is auditioning classes
that I was to do and not to do them I
would say to NYU and I wish we had had
audition class we never had on digital
probably invaluable I think it is I
think I've gone in and sat in the
casting office as a volunteer to read
and things like that is to see what I
see I hosted in everybody apparently
it's incredibly disturbing
no it's it's but you also see like you
see things and you realize very quickly
that oh that actor should not oh it's
only I mean they just start reading the
lines and he's walked in yeah you see
that it's it's good to just kind of walk
in you know be kind of neutral say hi
don't try to do too much and just do
your thing and walk out right you know
and some I have I've been on the other
side on the on the
camera and it is it is very interesting
it is very what do you think is the
number one can if you could even say
that's the number one mistake that
actors make when they go on to them like
that you get that you could say like
don't do this please
I think the the just kind of on a
general note I think it's it's and I and
I've been guilty of this is just trying
too much trying to be their best friend
trying to crack too many jokes trying to
you know letting your nerves kind of
take over and and trying to distract you
know from that I think it's best to just
kind of come in hey how are you you know
let me let me do this and do you think
it's important have your lines memorized
jeez it bother people are just reading
off a page if they're doing a great job
I you know I think that if you're doing
it depends on the way what you're doing
but yeah I know I think definitely
should be memorized I think you should
we hold in your script but I think you
know I'm always memorized you know I
think that that definitely I am too but
sometimes I just feel like maybe if I do
was less concern of us and went in there
as Catholics how the piece of paper
that's look at the badass thank you
doesn't give a you know just
wanting and not necessarily be concerned
about getting aligns right no no no your
can you getting the lance pekus there
they're just reading off the page you're
just not so concerned with having it
memorized like having created a
performance you know you're kind of just
in there just doing the thing with the
read here well i think i think it i
think yet at the end of the day you have
to walk in and you know even if you even
rehearse and rehearse the runners to
make the other day edit go in and just
you know do it with a performer
the reader you know I think that and
I've been guilty of this is kind of like
making it what I you know here's my
audition I shaped it like this this is
exactly what I want to bring in and I
Brianne and it's there's no life to it
you know I maybe I hit the beats right
but there there's no life to it you know
auditioning is so weird that's another
thing I mean you're reading with
somebody who typically is not another
rather they're like reading like recent
paper and then I love you too
what why did you kill my father okay
that's how I was gonna do the scene
though anyway I did that piece I
remember the one you're talking about I
did it exactly like that yeah yeah nail
it nail it
you